we've watched Encryption grow more
dominant and how we have a situation
where the major corporations are not
cooperating suppose that we had
legislation which required to where this
is headed is towards proposals for some
kind of stockpile of encryption key if
we're going to continue to preserve our
right to free speech in the electronic
age then we need to use tools like
encryption it just makes sense
hi I'm Zack wife's molar for a reason TV
here with Ladera Levison he is the
founder of lavabit the email service
famously used by Edward Snowden and
which he shut down in 2013 after the
government requested all the encryption
keys to access all the email on his
server we spoke about that about a year
ago at that time you said that you hoped
that the revelations would kind of
create a market do we have more
encryption than we did before has a
market in a desire for that arisen oh I
think it certainly has I think my
biggest problem I have with what's
happened in the last year is that
security and encryption have become
marketing terms and unfortunately we're
seeing this huge growth in the number of
encrypted communication services and
encrypted Internet services in general
but when you dig into the details
they're not truly secure how do you
drill down and figure out you know what
is real and and how does the layperson
know what is a good encrypted product
versus a bad one you mean without
getting a PhD in computer engineering
you have preferably it's really
difficult and you know I consider myself
to be I guess I'm going to use the e
word an expert and you know I can't
evaluate every product and service that
I use every application that I download
off the Play Store I really have to rely
on reputation
in a lot of instances one of your
current endeavors is something called
the dark male alliance which you're
working on with a team of other
high-profile people in the encryption
movement one of them Phil Zimmermann who
created PGP which is one of the first
like widely adopted methods of
encryption what are you hoping to
accomplish with the dark male alliance
to create a set of protocols that will
allow people to build email clients that
look and function identically to the way
they do today
but under the covers are capable of
encrypting that message before it leaves
your computer in such a way that only
the intended recipient can decrypt it
when it reaches the other end the tricky
part the part we're actually spending a
lot of time on right now refining is how
do we build a client that does that
encryption for you is completely
innocuous and user friendly to the
novice but still allows the expert like
me to easily go in and verify that the
encryption is happening properly and
that nothing is going wrong so when we
look at what happened to you and lavabit
who feds came in and basically asked for
the keys to the vault to be able to look
at everyone's email are you looking to
solve that problem then my system was
the best I could do ten years ago
without changing the protocols
themselves I took that like I would take
the laws of physics as an immutable
constant that I had to work around so
the system I built was focused on
protecting the messages why they were in
my control which is why they were in the
control of my servers so my system
didn't do anything to protect a message
before it arrived at lavabit or after it
left I relied on a internet standard
known as transport layer security or TLS
to create a wrapper an encrypted wrapper
around the connection between my server
and my users desktops and it was that
wrapper that the FBI wanted to peel
back so what I want to do is push the
encryption out of the server and on to
the users devices themselves right so
that way the sender would encrypt the
message before it even arrived at my
server and it wouldn't be decrypted
until it actually arrived at the users
desktop this is an issue that was raised
very recently in a congressional hearing
we cannot break strong encryption the
director of the FBI actually was telling
companies we need to have a kind of
backdoor around the encryption to fight
cyber terrorism
well what mr. Comey overlooked was that
this universal use of encryption has
become a requirement as a result of the
irresponsible use of surveillance tools
by his own organization if we want to be
able to have private conversations which
I feel is fundamentally necessary to a
free and fair democracy in order for it
to operate you know if we're going to
continue to preserve our right to free
speech in the electronic age then we
need to use tools like encryption it
just makes sense why is privacy
important to democracy and free speech
in your opinion because the rebuttal
that to that you always hear is if you
have nothing to hide why do you need to
build these you know brick walls around
your conversations because how do I get
exposed to ideas to people whose
opinions differ from me if I'm
constantly in fear of that Association
coming back to haunt my business
prospects you know people who attended a
Communist Party meeting once in college
because they were curious all of a
sudden were blacklisted and could no
longer work in Hollywood are you afraid
that the bad guys the terrorists will
use this technology to endanger America
and if that happens is are you afraid
there's going to be a huge government
push back against encryption technology
I'm not afraid of the pushback I am
afraid that terrorists will use this
technology certainly you know I don't
want to see anybody
any more than the next person which is
why I'm upset that I have to build a
milspec crypto communication system for
the entire planet just to say I love you
to a spouse another Internet freedom
issue that gets a lot of attention
especially from online activists is net
neutrality you've said that you think
going through the FCC is misguided why
the problem is that we view the Internet
and access to it as a utility it
shouldn't be viewed as a utility it
should be viewed as a commodity I want
to move us to a system closer to what
they have in the United Kingdom where
there's a neutral body that maintains
the line between the central office and
the end users home and that any service
provider who can run fiber to that
central office can offer Internet access
at whatever speed and price they they
think is appropriate and it's why for
the equivalent of 20 dollars you can get
a hundred megabit connection in the
United Kingdom whereas over here you
have to pay upwards of a hundred dollars
and you think that's because we realize
there's a little competition
alka and that's the real issue I mean
utilities the term itself refers to a
market and Industry a product or service
in which by its very nature there can't
be competition we've sort of grown up in
this world with the cable companies
because only one or two companies can
run wires to an individual's house so
that aspect of it the physical aspect of
it is still somewhat of a utility but
the service itself what goes over those
wires what goes through those pipes that
needs to be opened up to competition I
want to close with a question about
lavabit which you had to shut down
because you didn't want to compromise
all of your users data and just hand it
over to the government we're looking
back a few years at that are you still
glad that you did it and how did that
interaction with
governments affect your outlook and our
things better or worse so I wouldn't say
I'm glad I had to destroy the business
that took me ten years to create but
it's certainly a decision I would make a
hundred out of a hundred times because
it went against everything I felt was
important about how we we interact with
companies it violated that sacred trust
between a service provider and the user
it went against the very foundation of
why I started lavabit in the first place
which was to create the type of email
service that I would want to use myself
how has that changed me I I find myself
becoming more radicalized I love this
country
I I have trouble seeing myself living in
any other and I will continue to love
this country but what I despise is the
job our government is doing because I've
come to hate the government we have with
our Levison thank you very much for
talking to us you're welcome thank you
for having me
for reason TV I'm Zack Weissmuller